jawohl erzählt kann dass ich mich in den
argentinier verliert sind eigentlich
meine ältere mega of sexy und meine
mutter hat sich gefreut und ich ganz
glücklich und entspannt und sind sich
freut
das war den bahnhof sei das in einem
tango rivale assistentin eine klasse in
eine stunde eher instanz und der recht
sportlich sturm kommt und die hellen
soßen augenwinkel und architekt wow
und wie schon erfüllt aber ich eine noch
gar nicht richtig sehe wenn ich was am
schuhe bindet sie und eine dachanlage er
ist viel zu jung für mich und uns
station naja und dann hätt getanzt und
denn letztlich sogar tag füllt und ich
schätze sie und es kam die normalerweise
nacht eine ein stück man man
machtwechsel
ich wollte eigentlich nicht und nicht
ergebnisse nicht der ganze wie ist der
bald in excel oder mit mir tanzen kann
ja da sind
ich habe ich zwei also zwei makro und 63
minute und der tc mir gut gefallen und
dann einfach sagt der hundeführer
eigentlich fix und richtig besprochen
geplant
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wie gesagt wir wollen zusammen sein
das war egal ich kann nur sagen gute
mutter sein und ich musste natürlich
alles lernen nun die leute kennen werden
trotzdem werden auch mit mit der familie
von von er aus
ich konnte nicht als autolackierer
erhalten weil es ist wie man braucht
oder ich brauchte eine ausbildung als
autolackierer und ich habe meine
erfahrung ist ein abschluss passt genau
und dennoch liegt also bei fast 22
jahren
danke schön herr paß ich geboren
los herr zeit und probiere und gar
nichts viel luft auf die andere leute
dort umstände das einfach auf sich
selber sind und dass das leben ist nur
einmal lassen ich finde es ist jetzt vor
allem während des südamerikanischen
gedenken heute ist ich würde das heute
freuen
[Gelächter]